[Music]
foreign
thank you for being on my show thank you
for inviting me
okay disclaimer we are best friends for
many many years
and regardless you inspire me i admire
your work i admire the journey that
you've done
to get to this point we didn't meet the
conventional way that friends would meet
you know in school
or in the or in the boy scouts it's a
theme or something
we actually met for the first time at a
forbes conference
on the 1818 list and uh yeah so
so our friendship really started from
and you actually were you advised my
startup
back in high school so we didn't
actually become friends we first
worked together and then we became
amazing friends
how can we forget anything how can you
forget any meal and benny here also is
trying to say hi so now let
i was the one who chose the name for
your dog and
and and so you got the title of the
godfather as a result of that
yes so now it's official okay so you
know
you have a startup in the travel
industry so you
uh first hand are seeing the impact of
corona
and while that is fascinating i i do
want to start with
understanding how you got to this place
and you know
those are some things that you know
don't really appear on techcrunch and
they don't appear on the different
pr's that that we do and you came from
ashkelon from a different environment
and you paved your way to becoming a
very successful entrepreneur
and and i'm sure you're going to be
doing these incredible things also later
on
and so i'd love for you to spend some
time to tell me
where did you grow up how did you even
get to go into this tech world
and become one of the most connected i
think people in israel in the tech
industry
wow that's a lot of titles buddy um
so i started my journey when i was like
around
i think i was eight uh for it was my
first business
when i was i was selling headphones it
was a thing
when people started buying their first
home computers
and they were getting headphones for
free and they were pretty crap
so they were broken after a while and so
i was
uh reselling them i was taking these uh
headphones i was uh fixing them
with a friend of mine and then we were
selling them locally
uh to different uh shops and markets so
sort of
steve jobs and steve wozniak style right
yes kind of but in ascendant so it's a
very very small scale
so it was uh it was really really nice
so i think
you know if we if we want to speak about
my journey in the tech industry
we'll start from my background so my
background is uh
you know i'm coming from a middle uh
how do you say that um yeah you know
your family is you know you're you you
get by
exactly so and then you know money was
always an issue
and since i was very very young i was
trying to make money uh
any way i can and so um from
from one side and from the other side i
really love building stuff i really love
creating stuff i really
really love connecting stuff and making
something new
and i think i have i have been
developing my
imagination since i was really really
really really young
and so when i realized that i can mix
between making money and being super
creative and doing stuff
i realized how amazing is it it is to be
a tech entrepreneur because
i think and amir schwab told that in
your in one of your assassins
uh which was really really interesting
the
amount of time that you are or the
timeline from
imagination to execution is really
really short
and it's getting even shorter when time
goes on and the technologies are
sort of developing so when time goes on
i'm just being able to imagine whatever
i want and just to do it
very very very fast you know and i have
to say that
and we'll get to that later but you know
one of the best examples that i can
think of that is you know you're in this
crappy situation with
with corona in the travel industry and
and you know you're on one day you're
telling you're calling me and saying
michael
i don't know i don't know what's going
to happen right now with avian because
this is all so crazy who knows
how many months this will go on the next
day you're publishing that you have 500
participants signed up
for this the first online travel
conference with you know all the big
people on the travel so i think that's
exactly the idea so you grew up in
ashkelon and
from what i remember you travel quite a
bit to go to a specific school in tel
aviv
to get yourself a better education right
right so my parents uh really pushed me
to have
they wanted to be they wanted me to be a
doctor uh so they really really kind of
were pushing me
for towards a sign science way
or direction to make sure that i'm
getting the best education possible
and there was one school so my parents
are coming from the ussr
from you know ukraine and so there was
one school
which was full by kids of
people coming from the ussr it was like
uh russian speaking uh teenagers
but with really really high education in
science
technology and etc so i think i was
surrounded
in an environment full of innovation
technology and science since i was
really really young
having said that i'm not into math i'm
not into science really but
having all of this uh resources
with my imagination like literally gave
me all the resources needed to create
anything
i've been ever imagined and and that's
how i basically started so i had my
first
like company uh when i was 15 then
another one that was acquired it was 18
and then i joined rapid api
um because we met with idol
tax and y that you have organized in the
silicon valley
and et cetera et cetera et cetera so i
was whatever i've been able to imagine
i've been able to create
uh because of all of these resources
i've been growing up and
i think that's that's my journey so far
it's pretty i mean
i'm 26 in a week but it was
it's been a while i've been able to do a
lot of stuff and and i'm really really
grateful
so actually when this airs i believe
you'll already be 26 so happy birthday
uh so we'll treat it as if you're 26 now
so so now so you're the part of the
journey now where you you know you've
had some experiences in
in playing around with some ideas back
in high school and also and you know you
were in the army
and in the army you had a lot of
responsibility actually to
sort of guide people and decide on where
they will serve
within uh within the within the unit
i'd love to get your take you know you i
can't help but compare
what you did back in the army to what
you might have to do you sometimes as a
ceo and founder
when hiring people and finding the best
role for them
in different situations do do you find
that comparison is fair
um so it's it's not the same thing
because i was doing this in a very large
scale i've been
so i interviewed face-to-face i think
like
8 000 people in the army which is a huge
amount of people
from the tech units so from qa's to like
developers whatever um and it is it was
like a lot of responsibility because you
know
i i really didn't guide anybody i just
had to take the decision for them which
is much much harder uh
because you just have to look at
somebody
get a lot of data about this person and
then to decide
where is he going to give the best out
of him
to the army which is which was really
really hard from one side from the other
side you know me my like
because of this i have probably the
largest pool of developers and qas in
israel because i've
you know i've been able to get exposure
to so many of this
but one thing that it really really
helped me with is
really fast understanding what
is what will make what will make
somebody give a hundred percent
in the position he will be at because
i've been able to see so many cases
where people were placed in the army and
i
you know i made a lot of mistakes at 8
000 people is a lot of people but
um i've been able to create kind of a
skill of understanding
where a person will give the most out of
out of his skills
and that really helps me with my company
and really helps me with whatever i'm
doing because
whenever i'm i'm choosing somebody to
work with i feel
or at least like just develop the skill
that allows me to understand
how can i get the most out of him and
how to make sure that he will have
you know 100 fun and will do and will
grow 100
so that's basically how how the army
helped me
uh so much but it's really really unique
this position i've been to in the army
is
is different than you know than any
other one that i know uh in the tech use
for example
right and now transitioning to what
you're doing now so i
if i i'm looking back and you went so
you you you co-founded a
rapid api which is doing incredibly
incredibly well now
a lot also thanks to you and then you
took some break to do some more
consulting and helping other startups
find their way
and i remember that at some point you
came to me and said michael
you know i've been thinking of this idea
for a few months now i've done a lot of
due diligence on this and i think i'm
ready to move forward and start my own
thing
this is very different from the old
mickey that would have an idea overnight
and the next day would would just jump
straight into it so
walk me through some of your thought
process into the formation of what's now
called avion
so um after
leaving rapid api which was uh an
incredible
and like amazing journey yeah really
unique
um you know i was i was like sitting at
home and i was trying to
so i actually planned to go to like i
had an
opportunity to go to being a ceo and
another fashion technology company i
remember
and the company really survived and and
then i was like
you know in a situation where i had this
time to do whatever i want and then for
the first time in history
i did have the drive to do something but
i didn't want to focus on one thing
i wanted to taste a lot of different
worlds because i was into apis for a lot
of time and i was into
product management for a lot of time and
then i wanted to do something different
and i wanted to develop my my business
skills so
what i did is i started advising and
consulting like i think
over over nine or ten months
13 different startups uh in in
different categories so it was
blockchain and healthcare
and you know parking solutions and trump
and
a construction tech and and other stuff
and the goal was not to you know
not not to work on something specific
but to learn to
give my skills of you know whatever
fundraising product whatever i could
help with
and and connections but also learn about
new business models in different worlds
because i was really into one
and you know they were actually i wasn't
advising any
travel startups um but i did met
one person who used to run a a
travel management company you know an
old-fashioned one
and i was fascinated on
how old-fashioned this industry is
i mean you know it's a commodity now
you're going you're going you're flying
you're like
you're taking a bus it's basically the
same equipment um
and still all the backhand like
whatever is being managed there it's
very very old like 80s ninth
really really all and i was fascinated
how you know a 1.7 trillion dollar
industry
is using really really old-fashioned
tools
and i realized there might be an
opportunity there to start a company to
bring innovation
and that's how basically avian started
now as you can imagine every startup
is transforming pivoting changing along
the way
and so we started in a really really
different position we started
selling to directly to airlines and then
we pivoted it and started selling to
travel agencies
we started with a very enterprise
high level software that takes a year
and a half to sell
which is something that we can sell in a
couple of weeks we changed even more
into something that is more revenue
generating but one thing that i can tell
you for sure
is that the travel industry is go like
it's growing rapidly and you can see
trip actions growing rapidly with it and
other companies
travel perk and others but when you're
talking about the back-end side of it
it's still pretty old-fashioned and
because of different network effects and
because of different
oligopolies it's pretty hard to change
it so when you're getting into the
travel industry which is very attractive
in terms of innovation spaces
it is really really hard to move stuff
because by the end of it by the end of
the day these are
huge operations that are really hard to
change so that's what
what i like about the travel industry on
the other side
we can talk about it now um nobody could
ever prepare
for what is happening now which is i
think fascinating again
because you know you can say you can say
yeah so you could you could prepare for
a recession you could say there will be
an economic break whatever but you could
never imagine
that companies selling hundreds of
billions of dollars
in revenue just went down to zero in
literally like
seven days and that's why this industry
got
probably the hardest knockout
it it's even worse than 9 11
because it's not that people are you
know in 911 they closed some of the
air borders but now everything is being
closed and
psychologically people don't want to get
on board um
governments are shutting down like
airlines
and trying to keep them live all the
travel agencies are
losing like all the traffic they had
like literally a hundred percent
and it's a huge huge huge mess but one
thing that is really really interesting
is that this industry and i'm looking at
this now
is super super flexible and adaptive i
mean you can see how
the travel agencies now are changing
into more
hybrid models selling not only flights
but trying to kind of package stuff
for the day after corona you can see how
partnerships are
being made uh between companies that
don't even have a synergy
to create a more uh or wider consumer
experience for the travelers you can see
how airlines are now selling insurance
not only for
you know cancellations but for medical
equipments and etc because of these
stuff so
there is you know i was i looked at
there was a joke on linkedin that a
while ago about who forced
the innovation in your company was it
the ceo the
chief product officer or kobe so kovit
is probably the
uh most crazy uh innovation and
transformation
yeah yeah it's very funny amazing
now that i mean that that's just insane
so i mean you're you're sitting there
and you're
you know you have some funds and you
have you you expected a certain burn
rate and
a certain leeway for you to go and you
have you have over 10 employees right
working
working at avian and now you're faced
with a decision
you don't know what's going to happen
you don't know where this industry is
going
you are directly in between
travel agencies and airlines your
business is based on the premise that
people are willing to fly and that
airplanes leave
the ground and come back down what do
you do now
as a ceo what do you do so one thing we
were
i think both me and ron my co-founder
were prepared for is the recession so
everybody were speaking about this and i
was pretty anxious about this
since they won so we were really
really focused on being as lean as
possible
and make sure we can release uh on like
as fast as possible not to spend a lot
of money make sure that we have it
it's hard to raise funds in the travel
industry anyways
so and when you're preparing for a
recession it's another thing so right
when we got into this position into this
into this
uh um scenario we were ready for this so
that's a thing
and it's very very important from the
other side we did had
to to you know um uh
break up with a couple of uh colleagues
of ours
and to you know significantly uh get
down our burn rates
of course having said that and i think
the attitude
and that's something that you know that
i'm so grateful for
we are able if
so you took this uh this example of the
online travel conference
we had this idea one night
the night like it was thursday
over the weekend we've built every
everything all the infrastructure
furthest and two days after we had 300
participants
signed up and more interesting than this
we started generating revenue out of
this
so i think the cool thing about being a
very very very small company
is that you can be flexible enough to uh
to use the situation
and try to kind of leverage whatever you
have from the other side
you know on the travel perspective we
are trying to make sure
that when we're developing all of our
infrastructure which is you know default
but the
the second thing is that we realize that
all of our clients now
are pretty uh you know free so we've
been able to attract a lot of
uh clients and to integrate for them uh
to integrate with them for the day after
and and that's a really really great
opportunity having said that i know a
lot
i mean a list already of startups in the
travel industry
that were not prepared for this uh uh
scenario
and had a really hard hit and investors
had to get
involved into in the in this process and
to
kind of you know fund these startups of
course and uh get alive
and so it's it's a it's a really really
hard situation so i think it's
it's pretty it pretty depends on on the
company structure the problem starts and
that's where you can see it
you know globally now is that is where
you are really really become
such as expedia or or booking or
or united airlines or american airlines
or hopper or
any other travel travel travel uh sorry
companies that had to take
hard decisions to deal with this
thing because nobody knows when is it
going to end
and the other problem is that travel
will be probably
the last to recover so it's uh
it's it's really hard yeah well you know
i mean it's it's fascinating for me
uh through this show to to talk you know
both with
with venture capitalists as well as with
entrepreneurs and seeing the different
the different um the different mindsets
and one of the things that
that is really notable is how
everybody's in this together i mean it's
you know
everybody's impacted and everybody
together understands okay now we we have
to figure out how do we how we deal with
this together
we're not on two different ends of the
game and the whole world
is is realizing that this is not more
than ever this is a global
situation that it's not now it's not
every man for himself but we have to
figure out how do we cooperate together
and you know we both we we talked a bit
before about
you've all know hirari's post on on
globalization versus individualism in
times like this
and i think it's very very relevant
mickey before we go back
to you running a company and and me my
own things
i would love to know three things three
words that you best describe yourself
with
wow so hustling is number one oh yeah
hustling is the first one um
second is uh is a vision
because i really really love to imagine
stuff and see
yeah in the future and the third one
is you know it's not a one it's not a
one maybe
i don't know how do you say it so i i
just want to say that i really love
being surrounded by super super talented
people
such as you and my team at avn and thank
you all about my investors and
colleagues
so i think it's these are the three
things that i'm mostly focused on
i love it really i love it mickey thank
you so so much
and i'm gonna see you on our bff zoom
call with all our friends soon
probably probably soon and hopefully i
can see you in person at some point in
life as well right
yeah i'm not 12 000 kilometers apart
mickey thank you so much
bye buddy